bartenders your secret ingredient is
butterscotch chips seriously
butterscotch I died a little bit inside
the country's top bartenders converged
on Las Vegas to battle it out the games
create a signature cocktail using a
secret ingredient to be presented to our
esteemed panel of judges all before time
runs out
whoo we have three premier bartenders
competing for one place in our grand
final let's meet our competitors
I'm Seth I'm from Seattle Washington I
really enjoy the hospitality aspect of
tending bar my name is Leslie Ross and
I'm from Houston Texas it's very
important that my personality comes
through and everything that I do and
that really sets my cocktails apart am
tasty Roland I had the opportunity to
live in South Korea Germany Bosnia and
Sweden and being exposed to that many
different flavor profiles is helped
develop me as a bartender
welcome bartenders it's time to unveil
our secret ingredient with that secret
ingredient you'll have to create an
unforgettable gin cocktail and our
winner today will move through to the
grand finals with a chance to be crowned
America's bartender so you guys ready
bartenders remove the lid
your secret ingredient is butterscotch
chips I just started smiling and I got
this ball tennis your time starts now
I immediately run for a burner so that I
can get it on heat as fast as possible
trying to get that integration into the
liquid format of our cocktail is gonna
be a good challenge and I can see the
butterscotch being almost like a tidal
wave to the gym the fact that they're
chipped is pretty intimidating this is
an ingredient that I'm gonna have to
process
you can't just muddle it and throw it on
a drink I was definitely feeling my way
through picking up bottles putting them
down and trying to decide what to use
that's got a plethora of ingredients I'm
not too sure what he's got going on yet
I see some really amazing spirits on
Seth's table and I start questioning if
I picked the correct route to take Wow
no no I'm curious we have carrots coming
out I chose carrots because carrots have
a very strong and nice flavor I played
up the fact that there was a nutty
roundest I actually made a syrup in the
body of the cocktail by breaking down
the butterscotch chips with Amontillado
sherry I'll say this you have two
minutes left two minutes I was shaking
the cocktails there was an egg white in
it which takes a longer time to mull
suffice I'm literally counting down on
the clock as I go so that I still have
time to garnish the drink one minutes
ago I bought Edna's one minute and the
butterscotch just isn't melting at a
certain point I had to call it good in
order to continue with making my
cocktail I have to say that I could feel
the tension here it's really it's like
an earthquake I had totally tuned out
what anyone else was doing with this
kind of time constrain you're working on
the pipe this is going right down to the
wire six five four three two one step
away from the stations of these guys
times up there are question marks
everywhere you don't know what's going
to happen by the end of it you had no
idea and you were just in full-blown
panic mode
and it was it was rough bartenders great
job wasn't an easy challenge Stacy
please tell the judges about your
cocktail um I call this cocktail through
the looking-glass
referencing Alice in Wonderland just
because for me it really was a journey
of imagination he's the banana to kind
of provide a base that would support the
botanicals in the gin as well as
hopefully tie in butterscotch without
overwhelming the gin and drowning the
flavors that are naturally there I saw
you you know shaking up the egg whites I
really would have loved a little bit
more egg white consistency a little bit
more viscosity and then I think it would
have been for me out of the park Thank
You Seth excellent job please tell the
judges about your drink I called this
cocktail searider falcon I'm sort of
letting my nerd colors fly on that one
it's a name book from Battlestar
Galactica butterscotch is actually one
of my favorite desserts and I wanted to
offset the the richness of that and
embrace the Scotch enos of butterscotch
with a little bit of Drambuie and honey
to play with the more savory aspects of
Bombay Sapphire I wanted to counterpoint
that with some martini grandmas so to
give some undertones to that for what I
hope is sort of a bittersweet sipper
this is a for me I'm a man's man's drink
it's uh it's a little boozy though
that's my problem just a little bit too
much alcohol
maybe that will benefit from a little
bit more w while I'm while I'm drinking
it so good good work good drink
Leslee great job tell the judges about
your cocktail
so this cocktail is called what's
up-dock a clear reference to the carrot
I chose to use the butterfat that
already comes in the butterscotch as the
wait in the drink itself and I use dry
vanilla bean soda to help get me my
carrot base there what i tried to do was
do an after-dinner cocktail that was not
going to be heavy cream base and it also
highlights the botanicals in the gin the
colors phenomenal it's a little richer
than I would normally drink in a
cocktail but you did mention that your
it is an after-dinner cocktail so that
makes sense
I love the the fact that I can get the
vanilla bean in there I love that the
butterscotch is obviously the star of
the show
I think you've showed your navigation
today thank you bartenders phenomenal
job the winner of today's semi-final
advancing through to the grand final is
Leslie Leslie's what's up cocktail one
today because it led with imagination
the carrots blended with the
butterscotch chips in a beautifully
complex way that created a truly unique
drink Leslie you're gonna be going free
to the grand final congratulations it's
been over a year in preparation NEPA
parents's for this thing follow your
dreams
because it pays off work hard play
harder win want to try making this
winning butterscotch chip cocktail at
home give it a taste for more exciting
episodes subscribe to the GQ channel
you